I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hey, welcome back to Office Ladies. It is Angela Kinsey and Jenna Fisher and we're going to be talking today about health
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您录制独家《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历其中的两人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。嘿，欢迎回到《办公室女士》。我是安吉拉·金西和珍娜·菲舍尔，今天我们要谈论的是医疗
care. Health care. One of my favorite episodes from season one. I love it. I love this episode because to me it's The Office at its best because it's ordinary people doing ordinary things and it all goes south. And it's big stakes because having a job that has good health care is everything. So yes, today we are talking about season one, episode three, health care.
保健。医疗保健。我最喜欢的第一季剧集之一。我太喜欢了。我喜欢这一集，因为对我来说，这就是最棒的《办公室》，因为它是普通人在做普通的事，然后一切都搞砸了。而且赌注很大，因为拥有一份有良好医疗保健的工作意味着一切。所以，是的，今天我们讨论的是第一季第三集，医疗保健。
It was written by Paul Lieberstein who plays Toby Glenderson. Toby. Yes. It was written by Ken Whittingham. I love Ken. And we love Ken. Ken is the tall, gentle man. He is just so sweet and kind.
它由饰演托比·格伦德森的保罗·利伯斯坦编剧。托比。是的。它由肯·惠廷厄姆编剧。我喜欢肯。我们都喜欢肯。肯是一个身材高大、温和的男士。他是那么的甜美和善良。
Oh, you and I would talk to Ken all the time. All the time, yeah. Probably like too much. Like he probably at some point was like ladies like, I kind of have work to do and we're like, hi, Ken. He's just so lovely. We had Ken back a lot over the entire nine seasons. He directed nine episodes of The Office including Phyllis' wedding.
哦，你和我以前总是跟肯聊天。总是，是的。可能多到有点过分了。就像他可能在某个时刻觉得，女士们，我还有工作要做，而我们却说，嗨，肯。他真是太可爱了。在这整整九季中，我们经常请肯回来。他导演了《办公室》的九集，包括菲yllis的婚礼。
Yes. We had a little bit of St. Louis there. I did. I hear it every once in a while, but you said Aver. Oh, is that a St. Louis thing? I don't know, but you say some words like different. I think it's St. Louis. The biggest St. Louis thing that I don't do, but that Phyllis does, speaking of Phyllis,
是的。我们那里有点圣路易斯的味道。我有的。我偶尔会听到，但你说了“A韦尔”。哦，那是圣路易斯的口音吗？我不知道，但你有些词说得不太一样。我觉得那是圣路易斯腔。最标准的圣路易斯腔我没有，但菲yllis有，说到菲yllis，
is Fardy Farr. So we have a highway there called Highway 44. They call it Fardy Farr and you eat with a fark. Yeah. Sometimes rain and Phyllis sat back to back, you know. And every once in a while, rain would just turn around to Phyllis and say, Phyllis, say 44. And she would like, Phyllis, like when she gets really tickled, she snorts when she
就是Fardy Farr（四十四）。我们在那有一条高速公路叫44号公路。他们叫它Fardy Farr，你用fark（叉子）吃饭。是啊。有时候，瑞恩和菲yllis背靠背坐着，你知道的。每隔一段时间，瑞恩就会转过身对菲yllis说，菲yllis，说44。她就会像，菲yllis，当她被逗得很开心时，她笑得
laughs. So she'd be like, Fardy Farr. Okay. All right. Keep going. All right. Well, let me do a summary of healthcare. It's pretty simple.
会哼哧哼哧的。所以她就会说，Fardy Farr。好吧。好吧。继续。好吧，让我来总结一下医疗保健。这很简单。
Jan tells Michael that he needs to pick a cheaper healthcare plan for his employees to help prevent downsizing. Michael gives the job to Dwight and then hides in his office all day because he knows. Oh, yeah. No one is going to want their healthcare slashed. There's just classic Michael passing the buck. For sure. Which we're going to see over and over and over in the lifetime of the show.
简告诉迈克尔，他需要为员工挑选一个更便宜的医疗计划，以帮助防止裁员。迈克尔把这项工作交给了德怀特，然后整天躲在办公室里，因为他心里有数。哦，是的。没有人会希望自己的医疗福利被大幅削减。这绝对是经典的迈克尔推卸责任。肯定的。我们在整部剧的播出过程中会一遍又一遍地看到这一点。
So after Dwight picks a plan that slashes almost all the benefits and the entire office revolts, Michael promises us a surprise. Yes. Very big. Yes. Which is, which is what you do with your children when you have to give them right bad news, but there's going to be a surprise. It's so true.
因此，在德怀特挑选了一个几乎削减了所有福利并引发整个办公室暴动的计划后，迈克尔承诺给我们一个惊喜。是的。非常大。是的。这就好比当你必须对孩子们宣布坏消息，但又会有个惊喜时的做法。真是太对了。
And what I think is interesting is that everyone is skeptical, but also like, well, maybe there is a surprise. It's so sad. It could be a surprise. It's a little bit like Charlie Brown kicked the football, like, you know, when Lucy kept doing that. I feel like they're like, there's no way he's going to come through, but maybe because we hate our job so much.
而我认为有趣的是，每个人都持怀疑态度，但同时也觉得，嗯，也许真的有惊喜。太惨了。可能会是个惊喜。这有点像查理·布朗踢橄榄球，你知道的，就像露西一直做的那样。我觉得他们当时想的是，他绝对不会兑现承诺，但也许会有吧，因为我们太讨厌我们的工作了。
So maybe there'll be something that's going to happen. But then Michael has to spend the entire rest of the day scrambling to come up with something. Yeah. And what he comes up with is. Oh, just nothing. Just nothing. Yes.
所以也许会发生点什么。但后来迈克尔不得不花剩下的整天时间手忙脚乱地想出点什么。是的。而他想出的东西是。哦，根本什么都没有。什么都没有。是的。
All right, Jenna, do you want to do some fast facts? You know I do. I know you do. I know it. All right. So my first fast fact is that after the pilot episode, which we talked about was pretty much a word for word adaptation of the British pilot, because this was a British television show before it was an American television show.
好了，珍娜，你想做一些快速冷知识吗？你知道我想的。我知道你想。我太知道了。好吧，我的第一个冷知识是，在试播集之后——我们之前说过，它几乎是对英国试播集的逐字改编，因为在成为美国电视剧之前，这是一部英国电视剧——
After that, we started writing all original episodes. So diversity day was all original. It was our story. And this is all original with the exception of a little wink, a little nod to the British show. What trivia master? What? So in an episode of the British office, their Dwight character, whose name is Gareth, he
在那之后，我们开始编写所有原创剧集。所以多元化日完全是原创的。那是我们的故事。而这一集也是全原创的，除了对英国剧集的一点小小致敬和点头。什么冷知识大师？什么？所以在英国版《办公室》的一集里，他们的德怀特角色，名叫加雷斯，他
gets to lead an investigation into some dirty emails that came into the office. And so he takes over the conference room, and he even puts a little sign on the window. And that is the little thing that we stole for this episode, is that Dwight is going to do that same thing. He's going to take over the conference room. Yes. In this case, it is to pick a new health care plan for the company. So we did that from time to time.
有机会领导对办公室收到的一些不当电子邮件的调查。于是他接管了会议室，甚至在窗户上贴了个小标志。这就是我们为这一集借鉴的小细节，德怀特也会做同样的事情。他将接管会议室。是的。在这个案子里，是为了给公司挑选一个新的医疗计划。所以我们不时会这样做。
We just do like these little nods to the British show, which I always think are kind of fun, especially because there were people who were huge fans of the original who were then watching our show. And that was like a little treat. Well, I like it. I like where your head's at starting out this episode with some really good trivia, Jenna. I like where you're going. I like it.
我们只是对英国剧集进行这样的小小致敬，我一直觉得这挺有趣的，特别是考虑到当时有一些忠实的原版粉丝也在看我们的剧。这就像是一个小彩蛋。嗯，我喜欢。我喜欢你以一些非常棒的冷知识来开启这一集的心态，珍娜。我喜欢你的思路。我喜欢它。
I've got my note cards ready, lady. Do you want to hit me with a note card or shall I continue with fast facts? No, no, no. Do your fast facts. I've got some note cards waiting for you, though. All right. Well, this is a fast fact, and it's actually something, Angela, that you pointed out. Oh, is it a Kinsey fast fact?
女士，我的便签卡已经准备好了。你想用便签卡考考我，还是我继续讲冷知识？不，不，不。你讲你的冷知识。不过我确实有些便签卡在等着你呢。好吧，这是一个冷知识，而且实际上是安吉拉你指出的一点。哦，这是金西冷知识吗？
It's a Kinsey fast fact. Okay. That this is the first time we see Devon and Creed at their desks. Oh, yes. Yes. I love spotting little things in the background. Do you? I'm going to label you our background expert.
这是一个金西冷知识。好的。这是我们第一次看到德文和克里德坐在他们的办公桌前。哦，是的。是的。我喜欢在背景里发现一些小细节。是吗？我要封你为我们的背景专家。
No, don't. I'm not the expert. You are. You're making things. You really notice continuity stuff. Was it because you spent so much time in the background, Angela? Is that a dig? No, we all did.
不，别这样。我不是专家。你是。你真是无中生有。你真的很关注连续性方面的东西。是因为你在背景里待了太长时间吗，安吉拉？这是一个挖苦吗？不，我们都在背景里。
I'm totally kidding. No, we did, but I'm like... All right, Ms. Front Reception. Let me tell you something. Back in the accounting corner, we noticed Shataki. Okay. We noticed things. No, but you were always lurking back there.
我完全是在开玩笑。不，我们确实都在，但我是说……好吧，前台接待小姐。让我告诉你一件事。在会计角的那个角落，我们注意到了沙塔基（Shataki）。好吧。我们注意到了各种细节。不，但你总是潜伏在那里。
Lurking? So I thought, maybe... Now I'm a lurker? I thought maybe, you know. You're noticing more of what's happening back there. Some real truths coming out today. You know what I noticed in this episode that Jim has an E.T. on his desk. An E.T. doll.
潜伏？所以我当时想，也许……我现在成了一个潜伏者？我以为，你知道的。你更关注那里发生的事情了。今天有一些真实的真相要揭晓了。你知道我在这集里注意到什么吗，吉姆的桌子上放着一个ET。一个ET玩偶。
Oh, what? Like a little extraterrestrial doll. Yes, E.T. See what I'm saying? This is a Kinsey background observation. He's wearing, he's got a little E.T. on his desk and the E.T. is wearing like a blue coat. I have never noticed that. I know.
哦，什么？就像一个小外星人玩偶。是的，ET。看到我说的了吗？这是一个金西背景观察。他戴着，他的桌子上有一个小ET，而且那个ET穿着一件蓝外套。我从来没注意到过。我知道。
It's a, it's a, for you guys watching, it's at 14 minutes, around 35 seconds. There's an E.T. on Jim's desk and I'm like, what the heck? I don't remember that E.T. Anyway, see if you see E.T. at 14 minutes. Wow. See what I'm saying? You did have a note card. I have a ton of note card.
这是一个，这是一个，对于你们观众来说，在14分钟35秒左右。吉姆的桌子上有一个ET，我当时想，到底是什么鬼？我不记得那个ET了。总之，看看你们能不能在14分钟时看到ET。哇。看到我说的了吗？你确实准备了便签卡。我有成吨的便签卡。
There you go. I have more. Okay, go. All right, Angela. Here's my last fast fact. And this is something I learned when I was doing my prep for this episode and I listened to the DVD commentary. So this is the third episode of season one. However, we shot it sixth.
给你。我还有更多。好的，继续。好吧，安吉拉。这是我的最后一个冷知识。这是我在为这一集做准备、听DVD评论音轨时学到的。所以这是第一季的第三集。然而，我们拍摄它是第六集。
What? Yeah. I remember we shot the pilot and then we waited like six months to see if we got picked up. Yeah. And then when we did get picked up, the writers had turned in, like they had all their scripts ready for season one because there were only five more to do. That's right. We only did six. We did not shoot them in the same order in which they aired.
什么？是的。我记得我们拍了试播集，然后等了大约六个月，看我们是否会被续订。是的。然后当我们真的被续订时，编剧们已经交稿了，就像他们为第一季准备好了所有剧本一样，因为总共只有另外五集要拍。没错。我们只拍了六集。我们拍摄它们的顺序和它们播出的顺序并不一样。
So when we finished this episode, we all said goodbye. Oh my gosh. Do you know that? I remember that now. That puts a whole different filter on it now, like rewatching it because I feel like we were really loosey-goosey in this episode. I mean, we're going to talk about it, but a few of us just full on laugh and it's in the episode. But we were really, we were a tight knit group by the time we were filming this. Yeah, we were all pals at the time.
所以当我们拍完这一集时，我们都互相道别了。哦天哪。你知道吗？我现在想起来了。这给它蒙上了一种完全不同的滤镜，现在重新看它，因为我觉得我们在这一集里真的很随性。我的意思是，我们等会儿会聊到，我们中有几个人直接笑场了，而且这一集里还保留了这些画面。但我们确实是，当我们拍摄这一集时，我们已经是一个紧密团结的群体了。是的，我们当时都是好朋友。
And I think it shows in the episode. And I think that might also be why I have such like a warm place in my heart for this episode because when we were filming this episode, we really believed. We really, really believed that this was the last one we would ever do. Oh, for sure. I thought we were not coming back at all. And I had my name, like they printed out our name like on paper, but then laminated it, you know, for our trailer door. Yeah, with a little bit of Velcro. And that was on our trailer door.
而且我认为它在这集里展现出来了。我想这也是为什么我对这一集有着如此温暖的感情，因为当我们拍摄这一集时，我们真的相信。我们真的、真的相信这是我们拍的最后一集了。哦，肯定的。我以为我们根本不会回来了。而且我还把我的名字，就像他们把我们的名字打印在纸上，然后塑封起来，你知道的，贴在我们的化妆车门上。是的，带一点魔术贴。就贴在我们的化妆车门上。
And I took my little laminated piece of paper that said my name. Me too. I still have it. I still have it. You know what I did? What? I made a mix tape. Oh my God.
然后我拿走了那个写着我名字的塑封小纸片。我也是。我还留着呢。我还留着。你知道我做了什么吗？什么？我做了一盘混音带。哦天哪。
I made a mix tape and I called it something like Scranton Sound. Sounds of Scranton. Sounds of Scranton. And I gave it to John Raines Steve and BJ along with a tiny homemade scrapbook of some photos. And then, and then you said, hi, 1994 called. They want my mix tape back. I'm sure those guys were like this. And you were like the girliest present I've ever been given.
我做了一盘混音带，我给它取了个名字叫“斯克兰顿之声”之类。斯克兰顿之音。斯克兰顿之音。我把它送给了约翰、雷恩、史蒂夫和比杰，还附带了一本自己做的精美小剪贴簿，里面有一些照片。然后，然后你说，嗨，1994年打来电话。他们想要回他们的混音带。我敢肯定那些家伙当时的反应是这样的。而你的反应是，这是我收到过最娘娘腔的礼物。
I just picture you giving that mix tape to people and some people like they don't even have a tape player in their car. No one. It was a CD. Okay. It was a mix CD. I call it mix tape. Okay. I pictured an actual mix tape.
我简直能想象你把那盘混音带送给别人，而有些人甚至在车里都没有磁带播放机。根本没有。那是CD。好吧。那是混音CD。我叫它混音带。好吧。我脑海里浮现的是真正的磁带。
No, it wasn't a cassette. It was a CD. I am certain if I had to bet money, I am certain no one ever listened to it. Oh. I listened to it all the time. You listened to it in your car ride because it was, it was the sounds of Scranton for you. It was the sounds of Scranton. This is real.
不，不是盒式磁带。那是CD。我敢肯定，如果非要打赌，我敢肯定从来没有人听过它。哦。我经常听。你在车里听是因为那是属于你的斯克兰顿之声。那是属于你的斯克兰顿之声。这是真的。
So my commute to where we filmed the first season of the office was very long. It was over an hour because I lived in the San Fernando Valley and we shot in Culver City. And if you live in Los Angeles or have ever been here, that is a very long commute in the morning. Yes. And I wanted to quote unquote get in character. So I wanted to pretend like I was driving in Scranton. So I wanted some sounds of Scranton. Did you, did you like?
所以，我到《办公室》第一季拍摄地的通勤时间非常长。单程超过一个小时，因为我住在圣费尔南多谷，而我们在卡尔弗城拍摄。如果你住在洛杉矶或者来过这里，那早上绝对是一段很长的通勤路程。是的。我想“所谓地”进入角色。所以我只想假装我是在斯克兰顿开车。所以我想要一些斯克兰顿的声音。你，你喜欢吗？
I had a coffee. Research what people were listening to in Scranton. I didn't. How do you know? How do you know the sounds of Scranton? You know what? I really don't. I want to say I made a lot of assumptions.
我喝了一杯咖啡。研究一下斯克兰顿的人都在听什么。我没有。你怎么知道的？你怎么知道斯克兰顿的声音？你知道吗？我真的不知道。我想我做了很多假设。
And I kind of went back to my college days and I had some classic rock and a little bit of Garth Brooks. But now that I'm saying it, I realize I don't really know what East Coast people listen to. I was so whatever. It put me in a headspace. Well, I just want you to know, I want the sounds of Scranton on our website. I'm going to look for it. I want the pilots.
我有点回到了我的大学时代，听了一些经典摇滚和一点加思·布鲁克斯。但现在说出来，我意识到我其实并不知道东海岸的人都在听什么。我当时就是随便弄弄。这让我进入了一种心境。好吧，我只是想让你知道，我想把斯克兰顿之声放到我们的网站上。我要找找看。我想看看试播集。
I bet I still have it. Also, I want to know if it was. It's going to be embarrassing. If it was a CD, I want to know, did you make a little cover and write out each song? Or did you type them out and print it? Is there a photo? What's the cover of the CD? The cover of the CD is a collage of different pictures that remind me of Scranton.
我打赌我还在。还有，我想知道它是不是。这会很尴尬的。如果它是CD，我想知道，你是不是做了一个小封面，把每首歌都写在上面？还是你把它们打印出来的？有照片吗？CD封面是什么样的？CD封面是一张拼贴画，上面有各种让我想起斯克兰顿的照片。
Wait, wait, wait. It's printed on the back. No, no, no. No, wait. Please stop. Please stop. These aren't photos of people on the show. No.
等等，等等，等等。它是印在背面的吗？不，不，不。不，等等。请停下。请停下。这些不是剧里演员的照片吧。没有。
They're images of Scranton that you got from the computer. You got from the internet. And it's a collage. And so they're photos of Scranton. Yes. And it's called Sounds of Scranton. Right. And I would listen to it.
它们是你从电脑上找的斯克兰顿的图片。你是从互联网上找的。这是一个拼贴画。所以它们是斯克兰顿的照片。是的。名字叫“斯克兰顿之声”。对。我会听它。
And I would listen to it on my drive to get into the character of Pam. Oh my God. And then I would go to work. This is all why I love you. Because I want to be best friends with a person that prints images of places in Scranton. And makes a collage. And I accept a CD. As I'm telling this story now, it's occurring to me that when you live in a city, you don't
我在开车上班的路上听它，为了进入帕姆的角色。哦天哪。然后我就去上班了。这就是我为什么那么爱你的原因。因为我想和一个会打印斯克兰顿地方的图片并做成拼贴画的人做最好的朋友。而且我还收下了这张CD。当我讲到这个故事的时候，我突然意识到，当你住在一个城市里时，你不会为你居住的城市制作一张致敬CD的。
make a tribute CD of the city you live in. Well, guess what? I lived in St. Louis my whole life and I never drove around with a CD called Sounds of St. Louis. Well, I'm going to now, Sounds of Los Angeles. Let's make it. I didn't know what to give as a wrap gift. That's a thing.
好吧，你猜怎么着？我在圣路易斯住了大半辈子，从来没有开车放过一张叫《圣路易斯之声》的CD。好吧，我现在要做了，《洛杉矶之声》。我们来做一张。我当时不知道该送什么杀青礼物。这是一个传统。
Do people know that when you finish a series, when you finish a season of a show, it's sort of customary to give out little presents to your cast members or to some of your crew members. And so I really did not know what to give out. You know, Kate Flannery, I give out Sounds of Scranton. Kate Flannery had these Dunder Mifflin candles made. Do you remember that? I have it.
大家知道吗，当你拍完一部剧，当你拍完一季电视剧时，给你的演员同仁或剧组人员送一些小礼物通常是一种惯例。所以当时我真的不知道该送什么。你知道，凯特·弗兰纳里，我送了“斯克兰顿之声”。凯特·弗兰纳里让人制作了丹德米夫林的蜡烛。你还记得吗？我还留着呢。
I still have it. I have it. Yeah. But we really gifted. We were like, we're done. I got everyone to sign my script. So I still have that. And that's really cool.
我依然留着。我有。是的。但我们真的是送礼大师。我们当时觉得，我们拍完了。我让所有人都在我的剧本上签名了。所以我还留着那个。那真的很酷。
And Kate gave me a photo of her and I standing at our trailers because we shared a trailer. Kate and I had a trailer and just the only thing between our toilets was like a plastic accordion door. So if I sat on my toilet and she sat on hers, our knees touched. So we made a vow to never use our toilets. We were like, we just can't. We can't, that's just not going to happen. I remember that.
而且凯特送了我一张她和我站在化妆车前的照片，因为我们共用一个化妆车。凯特和我有一个化妆车，我们马桶之间唯一的隔断就像是一个塑料手风琴门。所以如果我坐在我的马桶上，她坐在她的马桶上，我们的膝盖会碰到。所以我们发誓绝不在那里上厕所。我们当时想，我们就是不能。我们不能，那种事是绝对不会发生的事情。我记得。
You remember our plastic accordion door? I do. It didn't even really shut. So we just opened it and just shared basically one room with two toilets. Well, when I think back to that time, I remember having anxiety about, I mean, I've just had the most thrilling experience of my acting life. I had been a struggling actor for eight years before I got my job on the office. I'd never had a regular role on anything.
你还记得我们的塑料手风琴门吗？我记得。它甚至都关不严。所以我们索性把它打开，基本上就是共用一个有两座马桶的房间。嗯，每当回想起那个时候，我都记得自己曾感到焦虑，我的意思是，我刚刚经历了演艺生涯中最惊心动魄的经历。在得到《办公室》这份工作之前，我曾做了八年苦苦挣扎的演员。我从来没有在任何作品中演过固定角色。
I'd done pilots, but they never got picked up. So this was my first series and I thought, well, what do I do if this show gets canceled? I guess I just go back to the beginning. I mean, we could have all had to go back and get day jobs again. I mean, so Kate Flannery and I both, we did not quit our day jobs for the first season of the office. Oh, I remember that Kate Flannery was still a waitress at Kate Manolini in Beverly Hills. And so she would work on the office and then she'd go wait tables.
我拍过试播集，但从来没有被续订过。所以这是我的第一部剧，我想，如果这部剧被砍了，我该怎么办？我想我只能回到原点。我的意思是，我们本可能都得回去重新找份白领工作。所以凯特·弗兰纳里和我都没有在拍《办公室》第一季的时候辞掉日常工作。哦，我记得凯特·弗兰纳里当时仍然是比佛利山庄凯特·马诺利尼餐厅的女服务员。所以她白天拍《办公室》，然后去端盘子。
I remember that. Yeah. And I was working at iOS, which was an improv theater and I was helping run the office and I stayed on and would help. Yeah. I just would have gone back to helping run a theater and improv classes and I ran the intern program. I fired someone who's now famous, one of my interns.
我记得。是的。当时我在iOS工作，那是一个即兴喜剧剧场，我帮忙运营办公室，我留下来帮忙。是的。我本来可以回去帮忙运营剧场、上即兴表演课，我还负责管理实习生项目。我开除过一个现在很有名的人，我的一个实习生。
Who? Can you say? He's a lovable person and I love him. Tell me. So this was my intern who was always late. He was always late. The higher ups said, okay, you can be late three times and then you get fired. And so as an intern, his job was to keep the restroom clean or he had come early set up
谁？能说吗？他是个可爱的人，我很喜欢他。快告诉我。所以这是我的一个实习生，他总是迟到。他总是迟到。高层说，好吧，你可以迟到三次，然后你就会被解雇。所以作为实习生，他的工作是保持洗手间清洁，或者他得早到布置
the box office. Okay. Like we needed him there early and he was late a lot, but I really liked him. And then finally they were like, you're going to have to fire him. So he walks in one day and his name is Derek Waters, creator of drunk history, creator of drunk history. And he walked in and he was really late and I was like, Hey, Derek and he was like, Hey, Angela.
售票处。好吧。就像我们需要他早到一样，他经常迟到，但我真的很喜欢他。最后他们说，你得开除他。所以有一天他走进来，他的名字叫德里克·沃特斯，《醉酒史》的创作者，是《醉酒史》的创作者。他走进来时真的很迟，我说，嘿，德里克。他说，嘿，安吉拉。
Are you going to fire me today? And I was like, I am. And he goes, okay. Oh my gosh, Angela, he told me the story. I wrote a book, everyone plug the actor's life, a survival guide. Check it out. Nice. Local books.
你今天要开除我吗？我说，是的。他说，好吧。哦天哪，安吉拉，他把这个故事讲给我听了。我写了一本书，大家去买《演员的人生：生存指南》吧。去看看。不错的。当地书店。
Nice. Local bookstores. Check it out. I wrote a book and I interviewed Derek in the book and he told me the story of being fired from IO. I did not know it was you that fired him. It was me. Well, it's still very much on his mind because he mentioned it in an interview.
不错的。当地书店。去看看吧。我写了一本书，在书里采访了德里克，他跟我讲了被IO解雇的故事。我不知道原来是你开除了他。是我。好吧，这件事到现在还在他脑子里挥之不去，因为他在一次采访中提到了它。
I know. But anyway, I would just go back to running a theater basically. I have something. So I know healthcare is about the office, finding a good healthcare plan and the downsizing. I know the overall arc of this episode, but I just want you to know, I have started calling this episode the Pam Sass. The Pam Sass. Uh-huh.
我知道。不管怎样，我基本上会回去经营一家剧场。我有件事。所以，我知道医疗保健这一集是关于办公室寻找一个好的医疗计划以及裁员。我知道这一集的大致剧情走向，但我只是想让你知道，我开始把这一集叫做“帕姆的毒舌”。帕姆的毒舌。嗯哼。
I'm going to come up throughout this episode where Pam is super sassy. Well, well. Uh-huh. It starts off right away when Michael comes up to you and you say, I'm not making any copies. Like you're sassy out of the gate, lady. And then, then you say, oh, do you want me to repeat the messages for the, and like you look to camera?
这一集中有很多帕姆超级毒舌的时刻。好吧，好吧。嗯哼。一开场就是迈克尔走到你面前，你说：“我不会复印任何东西。”就像你一出场就很毒舌，女士。然后，然后你说：“哦，你想让我重复一下这些留言吗……”而且你看向了镜头？
I have many more as we go through this episode. What were you, did I piss you off before you watched this episode and then you're just looking for sass moment? I am not. Hey, listen, you rewatch it and right away, you're just like, you are here, like you are not here to mess around. Sorry, you try having a boss like Michael Scott and see what kind of mood it puts you in.
当我们看完这一集时，我还有更多发现。你当时是怎么想的，是我在这集之前惹毛了你，所以你才一直在找我毒舌的时刻吗？我才没有。嘿，听着，你重新看一遍，马上就会发现，你当时，就像，你根本不是来这里混日子的。抱歉，你试着有个像迈克尔·斯科特这样的老板，看看它会让你陷入什么情绪。
Well, you were sassy in this one. I was matter of fact. Pam Sass. Oh my goodness. Okay, go, go on. What's out? What else is there? That's it.
好吧，你在这集里确实很毒舌。我只是就事论事。帕姆的毒舌。哦天哪。好吧，继续，继续。还有什么？没了。
All right, lady, I think we should take a break. I think we should, but I think we should tell everyone that when we come back from our break, we're going to have a special guest. Well, I think you just told them. I did. We're going to be a tall drink of water. Mm-hmm. Mr. Rainn Wilson.
好吧，女士，我想我们该休息一下了。我想是的，但我觉得我们应该告诉大家，当我们休息回来后，会有一位特别嘉宾。好吧，我想你刚刚已经告诉他们了。是的。我们将迎来一位高挑的水上佳人。嗯哼。雷恩·威尔逊先生。
Yes. It's time to break down the healthcare episode. Let's do it. All right, we're going to go a little rogue here. Okay. We're going to do a phone call with Rainn Wilson. With Rainn Wilson. Yeah, there were just too many things about this episode that were Dwight centered and
是的。是时候剖析医疗保健这一集了。我们开始吧。好吧，我们要有点出格了。好的。我们要给雷恩·威尔逊打个电话。跟雷恩·威尔逊通话。是的，这一集中关于德怀特的内容实在太多了
we had a lot of questions from fans that I think we needed to go straight to the source. We agreed. And Rainn said yes, and we're so thrilled. So we're going to talk to Rainn. We're going to call him. Let's call Rainn. Hello. Is this Rainn Wilson?
而且我们有很多来自粉丝的问题，我觉得我们需要直接寻找源头。我们一致同意。雷恩答应了，我们非常兴奋。所以我们要跟雷恩聊聊。我们要打电话给他。我们给雷恩打电话吧。喂。是雷恩·威尔逊吗？
Hey, Rainn. It is Rainn Wilson. Rainn Wilson. It's Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. What's up, fella? How are you? Thanks for doing this. I'm great, guys.
嘿，雷恩。我是雷恩·威尔逊。雷恩·威尔逊。我是珍娜·菲舍尔和安吉拉·金西。你好啊，老兄。最近怎么样？谢谢你参加。我很好，伙计们。
Yeah. I'm really good. I'm launching a podcast this week called Metaphysical Milkshake and I'm doing that with Reza Aslan. And is this in coordination with SoulPancake? It is, yes. And it's life's big questions of philosophy and psychology and spirituality and sociology and we're talking to some of the world's greatest minds with some super interesting stories.
是的。我真的很好。我本周正在推出一个名为《形而上奶昔》（Metaphysical Milkshake）的播客，我和礼萨·阿斯兰一起做的。这跟SoulPancake有关吗？是的，是的。这是关于人生中关于哲学、心理学、灵感和社会的重大问题，我们正在与世界上一些最伟大的头脑对话，分享一些超级有趣的故事。
I love that. And that launches very soon. That is so you, Rainn. That is so great. You are the person I go to with all of those questions in life. We can tell people, I have called you on occasion sobbing. You are my person that I trust with those big life moments. So this makes total sense.
我太喜欢了。而且很快就要上线了。这太符合你的风格了，雷恩。太棒了。你就是我遇到人生中所有这些问题时要求助的人。我们可以告诉大家，我有过泪流满面给你打电话的经历。你是我在那些人生的重大时刻中最信任的人。所以这完全说得通。
Sweet. It's true. That's so sweet. And I call you anytime I have an issue in the kitchen or anything with cooking or bread. Anything yeast related. I will say this though. Rainn, you know what I love is that you do reach out to Jenna and I in times when you're definitely wanting love and support and I love that we are all there for each other
太好了。确实如此。太贴心了。我每次在厨房遇到问题或者烘焙、做面包有什么状况都会给你打电话。任何跟酵母有关的事情。不过我要说的是。雷恩，你知道我最喜欢的是什么吗，你确实会在绝对需要爱与支持的时刻主动联系珍娜和我，我喜欢我们彼此都在那里支持对方
like that. It's true. Oh, yeah. You guys are like the sisters that I never had. Oh, you're too. We've talked about you a little bit like how you would look at us and say like, look at them. They're just like, they're two hens like, cluck, cluck, cluck, cluck, cluck.
的那种感觉。确实如此。哦，是的。你们就像是我从未有过的姐妹。哦，你们太……我们之前还聊过你，关于你是怎么看着我们然后说，看她们俩。她们就像两只母鸡一样，咯咯咯，咯咯咯。
They will not stop talking. Blah, blah, blah. Blah, blah. Blah, blah. I mean, if the listeners could only know what those conversations were like on the set. I mean, it's just like, I made the best lasagna you did. I love lasagna.
她们根本停不下来。喋喋不休，喋喋不休。喋喋不休。我的意思是，如果听众们能知道我们在片场的那些对话是什么样的就好了。我的意思是，那就像是，我做了最好吃的千层面，你做的也是。我喜欢千层面。
One time I went to Italy. I had lasagna. One time I went to Italy. I've been to Spain. What time? I like Spain. I mean, rain. Rain.
有一次我去了意大利。我吃了千层面。有一次我去了意大利。我去过西班牙。哪次？我喜欢西班牙。我是说，雷恩。雷恩。
So handsome. Do you like ham? I love ham. They weren't even that interesting rain. They weren't even that interesting. That's way more interesting. That is like way more, way more fascinating than anything we ever talked about for hours on end.
你那么帅。你喜欢火腿吗？我爱火腿。它们甚至都没那么有趣，雷恩。它们甚至都没那么有趣。那要有趣得多。那比我们几个小时以来谈论过的任何事情都要迷人得多、引人入胜得多。
That's fantastic. It's so true. Okay. Well, we have some questions for you about the healthcare episode. We do. All right. Go. We have some questions for you about the healthcare episode, which is appropriate because this
太棒了。确实如此。好的。好吧，我们有一些关于医疗保健这一集的问题要问你。是的。好吧。问吧。我们有一些关于医疗保健这一集的问题要问你，这很合适，因为这一集
is a Dwight A. storyline. Big storyline. One of your first real big one, right? Wow. Thanks, guys. Thanks for the support. Yeah. From 2004.
是德怀特的主线剧情。重大剧情。你的前几个真正的大主线之一，对吧？哇。谢谢你们。谢谢你们的支持。是的。从2004年开始。
Yeah. Thank you. Hey, you did some great stuff a decade ago. Don't get it. It's true. All right. So I want to, I want to ask you, Rain, just what comes to mind for you when you first think of the healthcare episode?
是的。谢谢。嘿，你十年前做了一些很棒的事情。别这样。确实如此。好吧。所以我想问你，雷恩，当你第一次想到医疗保健这一集时，脑海里首先浮现的是什么？
That was the first episode that I remember that we spent an inordinate amount of time in the conference room. Yeah. And I remember saying hot dog fingers. Hot dog fingers. That was very funny. Hot dog fingers. Which totally made us break.
那是让我印象深刻的第一集，我们在会议室里花了大量的时间。是的。我记得我说过热狗手指。热狗手指。那太搞笑了。热狗手指。这完全让我们笑场了。
And they left it in the episode. Rain, I full on start laughing. And then Brian breaks character and points to me and starts laughing and it's still in the episode. That is your real laughing in that. That's me really laughing. It's true. They left in the edit.
而且他们把它留在了剧集里。雷恩，我直接大笑起来。然后布莱恩也出戏了，指着我开始笑，这幕到现在还在正片里。那是你真实的笑声。那真的是我在笑。确实如此。他们在剪辑时保留了
You guys breaking. They're cracking over these diseases. It's truly hysterical. But I do remember saying to Kate Flannery, didn't I say like, you had your vagina removed and she's like, it was a hysterectomy, it was my uterus or something like that. I still have a vagina. Yes. That was in the conference room.
你们笑场的镜头。他们被这些疾病名字逗得崩溃了。真的太滑稽了。但我确实记得我对凯特·弗兰纳里说过，我是不是说过，你切除了阴道，然后她说，那是子宫切除术，那是我的子宫之类的话。我还有阴道。是的。那是会议室里的情节。
But when you first come out, this is a frequently asked fan question, which is, did you guys improvise the fake diseases or were they scripted? And I remember that there were scripted fake diseases. But then at a certain point, just Paul and the director and other writers came down and they were just handing you a piece of paper with improvised fake diseases. And none of us knew you were going to say hot dog fingers. It was a complete nutter surprise that was not in the script. Do you remember that?
但当你刚走出来时，这是一个经常被粉丝问到的问题，那就是，那些假疾病是你们即兴发挥的还是剧本写好的？我记得里面确实有一些剧本写好的假疾病。但后来在某个时刻，保罗、导演和其他编剧下来了，直接递给你一张写有即兴假疾病的纸条。我们谁也不知道你要说热狗手指。这是一个完全出乎意料的惊喜，根本不在剧本里。你还记得吗？
Yes. There were some very funny ones that were scripted and nano robot, micro invasion or whatever that one was, that was in there and a lot of great ones were in there. But yeah, they kept feeding the other ones. It was very hard for me to keep a straight face. I wrote all the time. I know. I remember thinking, how are we going to have any usable takes?
是的。剧本里有一些非常搞笑的，比如纳米机器人、微创入侵之类的，那都在剧本里，还有很多很棒的都在里面。但，是的，他们不断地给我们塞新的。要保持严肃对我来说太难了。我一直在笑。我知道。我当时想，我们怎么可能拍出任何能用的镜头？
I just know. Because we all kept laughing. You know, you get to a certain point in laughing when you just cross a line where you've just been tickled too much and you just can't bring it back. Yes. That happened. You know, that happened maybe like, I won't say every episode, but every two to three episodes that kind of happened for me and it absolutely happened in this one.
我太知道了。因为我们一直在笑。你知道的，笑到一定程度，当你越过那个界限，被逗得太开心而无法恢复时。是的，这种情况发生了。你知道，这种情况大概，我不会说每一集，但每两到三集就会发生一次，而这一集绝对发生了。
But my friend Kevin, Kevin Isolo is an actor in New York. He was visiting the set and he was the one who actually threw out hot dog fingers. Oh my God. Oh my God. Amazing. Kevin. That's his claim to fame. Yeah.
但我的朋友凯文，凯文·伊索洛是纽约的一名演员。他当时来片场探班，正是他随口说出了“热狗手指”。哦天哪。哦天哪。太惊艳了。凯文。那是他的成名之作。是的。
His claim to fame. I hope he has a shirt that just says hot dog fingers. I mean, I feel like we- I am going to buy him that shirt right now. Send that to him. That would be a really good shirt. It would be. Wasn't it?
他的成名之作。我希望他有一件只印着“热狗手指”的衬衫。我的意思是，我觉得我们——我马上要给他买一件那样的衬衫。寄给他。那会是一件非常棒的衬衫。确实如此。是不是？
Yeah. Hot dog fingers. Rain, you have one of my favorite talking heads in this episode. I mean, there's so many. You have so many good ones over the years, but this is like the one, definitely season one, that is like- It sort of is like the quintessential inn for Dwight. Yes.
是的。热狗手指。雷恩，这一集里你有我最喜欢的访谈镜头之一。我的意思是，有很多。这些年来你有太多精彩的访谈了，但这绝对是第一季中最经典的——它有点像是德怀特的精髓所在。是的。
It's the lion. Like your whole rant about, in the wild, there is no healthcare, in the wild, healthcare is- Right. Ow, I hurt my leg. Should we play it? Yeah. Do you want us to play it, Rain?
就像那句台词。就像你关于“在野外没有医疗保健，在野外医疗保健就是——”的长篇大论。对。哎呀，我腿受伤了。我们要放一下吗？是的。雷恩，你想让我们放一下吗？
We have that ability here. Do you want to hear it? We're really high tech. Yeah, I love it. Yeah. You want to listen to yourself deliver a great talking head? I do. In the wild, there is no healthcare.
我们这里有这个功能。你想听吗？我们技术很先进。是的，我很喜欢。是的。你想听听自己发表的一段精彩访谈吗？我想听。在野外，没有医疗保健。
In the wild, healthcare is, ow, I hurt my leg. I can't run. A lion eats me and I'm dead. Wow, I'm not dead. I'm the lion. You're dead. I love that so much. Oh my gosh.
在野外，医疗保健就是，哎呀，我腿受伤了。我跑不动了。狮子把我吃掉了，我死了。哇，我没死。我是狮子。你死了。我太喜欢这段了。哦天哪。
The only thing I'll say about that one was, you know, we were really establishing Dwight and his logic and how seriously he took himself and these kind of rules that Dwight started to develop where he's very hierarchical and status and like, this is how things must be done. But he has a completely different set of rules than other people do. Just how he sees the, one of the things I think that has given the character enduring appeal is he sees the world in a very clear way with these kind of stratum, stratum hierarchies of rights and wrongs and moralities and how things work and how they should work and they're
关于那段话，我只想说，你知道，我们当时真的在确立德怀特这个角色及其逻辑，他有多么认真地对待自己以及德怀特开始形成的这些规则，他非常看重等级制度和地位，觉得事情必须这样办。但他有一套与其他人完全不同的规则。仅仅是他看待世界的方式，我认为赋予这个角色持久吸引力的原因之一，是他以一种非常清晰的方式看待世界，有着这种等级、权利和错误、道德以及事情如何运作以及应该如何运作的阶层，而且它们非常严格，这是深入探讨德怀特那个世界的首批访谈之一，这全都要归功于保罗·利伯斯坦。他写了这段台词，而且他对它非常满意，他非常高兴能帮忙，他 realmente 帮了不少忙。他当时虽然没有导演这一集，但他就在旁边，对不同的语调和表达方式给出了大量的意见。哦，哇。有趣，有趣。
very severe and this is one of the first talking heads that kind of like dove delved into that world of Dwight and it's all Paul Lieberstein. He wrote that and he was very happy with, he was so excited to kind of help, he really helped direct. He wasn't directing the episode but he was right there kind of giving a ton of notes on different inflections and ways to say it. Oh, wow. Interesting, interesting.
好的。是的。这完全是随机的，雷恩，在重看这一段时，在那段访谈期间，你正在分发新的医疗计划。你把它们扔给人们。你在办公室里把它们传阅开来，看起来你的嘴里好像含着棒棒糖。当你分发所有这些文件时，你嘴里伸出了一根白色的棍子。安吉拉，关于这个播客，你有一点应该了解，雷恩，那就是安吉拉总是在
Okay. Yeah. This is totally random but Rain, in re-watching this, during that talking head, you're passing out the new healthcare plan. You're tossing it to people. You're handing it around the office and it looks like you have a lollipop in your mouth. There is a white stick sticking out of your mouth as you're passing all these papers out. Angela, you should know something about this podcast Rain which is that Angela is constantly
捕捉这些奇怪的小细节。好吧，我只是觉得，当我重看时，我脑子里想的是，雷恩饰演的德怀特，你是在分发这些文件时吮吸着棒棒糖吗，因为这太绝了。我对此毫无记忆，但我猜我可能确实在吸。是的。你看，在大约4分钟50秒的时候，你好像有，看起来你嘴里含着棒棒糖。你听到了吗？
picking up on these weird little details. Well, I'm just like, what the heck when I re-watched, I'm like, does Rain as Dwight, are you sucking on a lollipop as you're passing this out because that's brilliant. I have no memory of that whatsoever but I think maybe I was. Yeah. Well, look, around four minutes, 50 seconds, you'd like have, it looks like a lollipop in your mouth. Did you hear that?
4分钟30秒。不，50秒，大约50秒。50秒。你就像漫不经心地分发着这些文件，同时还吮吸着棒棒糖。我觉得这真的很酷很有气势。我不知道。我太喜欢了。好吧，这就引出了吉姆和帕姆与你对质的场景，
Four minutes, 30 seconds. No, 50, around 50 seconds. 50 seconds. You're just like flippantly passing these papers though, sucking on a lollipop. I thought it was really cool and powerful. I don't know. I loved it. Well, this leads us into the scene with Jim and Pam confronting you about, confronting
质问德怀特为什么挑选了一个削减所有福利的糟糕计划。你还有所有那些其他精彩的“德怀特语录”，比如你说你从来没有生过病，你有着惊人的免疫系统，对此，你知道的，我们问你既然从来没生过病怎么能拥有伟大的免疫系统，而你的回答是你有伟大的基因，然后你接着说你可以随意提高和降低你的胆固醇。而我说，你为什么会想提高胆固醇呢，你说，这样我就可以降低它了。我记得当时和你拍那场戏，我还记得那是台词对白，我怎么都背不顺。
Dwight about picking a horrible plan where he slashed all the benefits. You have all those other great Dwight-isms where you say you've never been sick, that you have an amazing immune system to which, you know, we ask you how can you have a great immune system if you've never been sick and it's just you have great genes and that's when you say that you can raise and lower your cholesterol at will. And I say, why would you want to raise your cholesterol and you say, so I can lower it? I remember shooting that scene with you and I remember that was the couplet that I couldn't get through.
为什么你会，那就是难倒我的那句词。这其实是一个粉丝提出的问题，克里斯托弗问，你和雷恩拍胆固醇那场戏拍了多少次，我不记得具体拍了多少次了，但绝对很多次，克里斯托弗。是的，很有趣的是，在《办公室》的历史回顾中，会冒出这些后来成为该角色经典名言的台词，而且很有意思的是，你知道，对于德怀特来说，大约有15到20句经得起时间考验的“德怀特语录”，粉丝们非常喜欢，你知道的，比如身份盗窃不是个笑话，吉姆，你知道的，
Why would you, that was the one that got me. And that was a question from a fan actually, Christopher said, how many times did it take for you and Rain to get through the cholesterol scene and I can't remember how many times, but it was a lot, Christopher. Yeah, it's funny how in history, looking back on the office, there are these quotes that pop out that become like the classic quotes of the character and it's, it's interesting that, you know, for Dwight, there's like 15 or 20 kind of Dwight-isms that stand the test of time and that fans love to, you know, identity theft is not a joke, Jim, you know,
其中一些台词，而胆固醇那句绝对是其中之一。我觉得另一个人们常谈论的梗是“巧克力伯爵”，也就是你跟吉姆对质的那场戏，不过这一段其实最后被剪掉了，并没有出现在正片里，你当时其实跟办公室里的好几个人都开了会。你拍了一段和奥斯卡对质的戏，你好像和他也开过会，对吧，安吉拉？而且很简短。可能吧。
some of these ones and the cholesterol one is definitely one of them. I feel like another one of those phrases that people talk about is the count chocolateus, the scene when you are confronting Jim, but also something that ended up on the cutting room floor from this where you actually had meetings with a bunch of people in the office. You shot something where you confronted Oscar, you had, I think you had a meeting with him, didn't you, Angela? And it was very short. Probably.
他在片中问你是不是那些假疾病是你写的，因为他把每个人都盘问了一遍。好吧，在与吉姆的面谈中，你说，巧克力伯爵，你为什么写下这个，吉姆，是因为你知道我喜欢巧克力伯爵吗？我太喜欢你喜欢巧克力伯爵这个设定了，这就是德怀特早晨的早餐，或者可能是深夜看电视时的零食。是的，也许是个零食。也许他以巧克力伯爵为榜样，也许他，他对巧克力伯爵有着一种喜爱，这个角色，麦片背后的那个人。是的，是的，甚至不是麦片。不是麦片。这个角色。没错。他喜欢巧克力伯爵，也就是那个麦片人物。他更多的是与真实的巧克力伯爵产生连接，他能跟那个角色共鸣。是的。
Where he asks you if you wrote the fake diseases, because he goes through and like interviews people. Well, in your interview with Jim, you say, count chocolateus, why did you write that down, Jim, is it because you know I love count chocolate? I love the idea that you love count chocolate, that that's what Dwight has for breakfast in the mornings or maybe late at night while he's watching TV. Yeah, maybe it's a snack. Maybe he models himself after count chocolate, maybe there's a, he has an affinity for count
好吧，你刚才提到了。还有会议室的那场戏，你开始宣布各种病症，你告诉我们，如果我们想要医疗保险覆盖，就必须承认并承认那是一种真正的疾病。然后你跟梅雷迪思就有了那段互动，她说，你提到“阴茎内陷”。她说，你指的是阴道吗，如果是的话，我希望这个能报销。然后，然后你提到，我以为你没有阴道，你做过子宫切除术，接着她说了那句绝妙的台词。我还有阴道。
chocolate, a character, the person behind the cereal. Yeah, yeah, not even the cereal. It's not the cereal. The character. That's right. He loves count chocolate, the cereal. He's more just connected to actual count chocolate, he relates to him. Yeah.
巧力特，一个角色，这个麦片背后的那个人。对，对，甚至不是麦片。不是麦片。是那个角色。没错。他热爱伯爵巧力特，也就是那个麦片。他其实更喜欢真正的伯爵巧力特，他能和他产生共鸣。对。
Well, you brought it up earlier. There's also the conference room scene when you start announcing ailments and you tell us that if we want it covered, we have to fess up and admit that it's a real disease. And that's when you have that bit with Meredith where she says, you say inverted penis. And she's like, she said, do you mean vagina because if so, I want that covered. And then, then you bring up, I thought you didn't have a vagina, you had a hysterectomy and then she has that great line. I still have a vagina.
好吧，你刚才提到了。还有会议室里的那一幕，当时你开始宣布各种病痛，并告诉我们，如果我们想要报销，就得承认那是一种真正的疾病。然后你和梅雷迪思有这样一段互动，她说，你说了个倒置的阴茎。然后她说，她是说，你是说阴道吗，如果是的话，我想报销那个。然后，然后你提起，我以为你没有阴道，你做过子宫切除术，接着她说了那句绝妙的台词。我还有阴道。
Yeah, I think I improvised, I improvised that. And this was early on, we started to kind of like improvise a little bit more. Wait, you improvised that she had a hysterectomy? Did you improvise that because that pays off later in another episode? No, no, no, no, no, that was in there, the hysterectomy, but I, the line that I thought you didn't have a vagina was mine. Oh, okay, yeah. That sounds like you.
是啊，我想我当时是即兴发挥的，那是即兴发挥的。那是早期的时候，我们开始稍微多做一点即兴发挥。等等，你即兴发挥说她做了子宫切除手术？你这么做是因为这在后面的另一集里会有伏笔吗？不，不，不，不，不，子宫切除那段本来就在剧本里，但是，我认为你没有阴道那句台词是我想的。哦，好吧，是的。听起来确实像你会做的事。
Isabel has been wanting to watch The Office Reign and I, I haven't let her yet, but now like all of her friends have seen it in fifth grade and so I let her watch this episode with me. In fifth grade? Her friends have seen The Office? Her friends, oh my God, they're obsessed. Yeah. Oh, that's when it starts now.
伊莎贝尔一直想看《办公室》，而我，我还没让她看，但现在她在五年级时，她所有的朋友都已经看过了，所以我让她和我一起看这一集。在五年级？她的朋友们看过《办公室》？她的朋友们，天哪，他们都迷上了。是的。哦，现在就是从这个时候开始的。
That's when it starts. Fifth grade. Fifth grade. But fifth grade is young. Fifth grade is young. And so Isabel hasn't seen The Office and I, I didn't have her watch it because I didn't think it was age appropriate and also I just need to be mom, you know, and, but she's getting more curious now.
就是从这个时候开始的。五年级。五年级。但五年级还小。五年级还小。所以伊莎贝尔还没看过《办公室》，我，我没让她看，因为我觉得这不适合她的年龄，而且我也需要扮演好妈妈的角色，你知道的，但是她现在越来越好奇了。
And so she loves the bloopers. So we've watched the bloopers because they were on YouTube and then I was rewatching this episode and she wanted to watch it. So I let her watch it with me and it's, so her, her introduction to The Office is healthcare. Oh my goodness. And, um, so anal fissures. That's it. That's it.
所以她很喜欢NG镜头。我们看过NG镜头，因为它们在YouTube上，然后我在重看这一集时，她想看。所以我让她和我一起看，所以，她的，《办公室》的初体验就是“医疗保健”这一集。哦，天哪。然后，嗯，还有肛裂。就是这样。就是这样。
That scene came up and she was like, wait, mom, that's not a real thing. Is it? What is that? And I was like, oh God, it is a real thing. And then she's like, but if you ride on the New York, uh, if you ride on the New York subway, they have ads up for anal fissure. There you go. You read all about them.
那一幕出现时，她说，等等，妈妈，这不是真的吧？是什么？然后我说，哦天哪，这是真的。接着她说，但是如果你坐纽约，呃，如果你坐纽约地铁，他们会贴出肛裂的广告。给你找到了。你对它们了解得一清二楚。
Well, Isabel turned to me and goes, does Brian have anal fissures? I'm like, no, no, Brian doesn't. Brian does not. Kevin does. Kevin does. And anyway, it was just sort of funny to, to watch the episode with her. Well, this is a little bit off the topic of healthcare, but a little on the topic of just how we're friends in real life.
嗯，伊莎贝尔转向我问，布莱恩有肛裂吗？我说，没有，没有，布莱恩没有。布莱恩没有。凯文有。凯文有。不管怎样，和她一起看这一集真是挺有趣的。好吧，这有点偏离了医疗保健的话题，但有点贴近我们在现实生活中是如何成为朋友的话题。
People ask that all the time. We're friends in real life, right, Rain? Rain? Yes. Yes. Yes, we are. Jenna. Okay.
人们经常问这个问题。我们在现实生活中是朋友，对吧，雷恩？雷恩？是的。是的。是的，我们是。珍娜。好吧。
We've gone to lunch. We text. Do you need, do you need a firming? Can I get this in writing? No. Okay. No, that we're all friends in real life and they shared so much of our lives, uh, doing the show for so long, I remember that, um, your wife holiday was pregnant with your son
我们一起吃过午饭。我们发短信。你需要，你需要一个确定的答复吗？我能把这个写下来吗？不。好吧。不，我们在现实生活中都是朋友，他们分享了我们生活中的很多点滴，呃，拍这部剧那么久，我记得，嗯，你妻子霍莉在怀你儿子的时候
when we were shooting the pilot. Yes. And then I remember how he was born during an episode, but Rain, I couldn't remember which episode it was. We were shooting. So Walter, Walter was born during the hot girl person, first girl episode. Oh, right. So they shot me out the first two days.
我们在拍试播集。是的。然后我记得他是生在某一集拍摄期间，但是雷恩，我不记得那是哪一集了。我们在拍。所以沃尔特，沃尔特是在辣妹那一集，第一个女孩那一集出生的。哦，对了。所以他们把我前两天的工作集中拍完了。
They just were like, Oh, well, just shoot all rain scenes on Monday and Tuesday. And then sure enough, late Tuesday night, Walter was born and it was a horrific, uh, ugly, difficult birth and, uh, we were in the hospital emergency room and all that kind of stuff. You can read about that in my book. Yeah. The Bassoon King. Yes.
他们当时就说：“哦，好吧，那就把雷恩所有的戏份都在周一和周二拍完。”果不其然，周二深夜，沃尔特出生了，那是一场可怕的、糟糕的、艰难的分娩，呃，我们在医院急诊室，诸如此类的事情。你可以在我的书里读到这些。是的。《巴松王》。是的。
Yes. Available now. Mm-hmm. No, I wasn't talking to you two. I was talking to all the listeners out there. Listeners, if you want the full story, you can read about it in the Bassoon King. Get Rain's book. The Bassoon King.
是的。现已发售。嗯哼。不，我不是在对你们两个说。我是对所有的听众说的。听众们，如果你想要了解完整的故事，你可以在《巴松王》里读到。去买雷恩的书吧。《巴松王》。
Yes. It's a very good book. So that was kind of crazy. And then I had a couple of days off and, uh, I don't, I think it just came in Monday. We shot out of order. Yeah. So because that, um, hot girl is the last episode that airs for season one, but it was, we shot it in the middle.
是的。这是一本非常好的书。所以那真是有点疯狂。然后我有几天假，呃，我不知道，我想我是周一来的。我们是打乱顺序拍的。是的。因为，“辣妹”是第一季播出的最后一集，但它是，我们在中间拍的。
Healthcare was actually the last episode that we shot. And you had a little tiny Walter while you were shooting this episode. Yeah. And I remember you had to come back to work Monday. You only had what? You were so tired. Five days off after he was born. We spent the whole weekend in the hospital.
“医疗保健”实际上是我们拍的最后一集。你在拍这一集的时候，沃尔特还是个小不点儿。是的。我记得你周一必须回去上班。你只有什么？你太累了。他出生后休息了五天。我们在医院度过了整个周末。
We were, my wife was in the hospital for like four or five days. So we went home from the hospital, maybe Sunday night or even that Monday morning and I came to work on Monday. You came to work. Oh my God. And I remember being worried. I remember just thinking, just being concerned for- I hope that you guys are okay.
我们，我妻子在医院住了大约四五天。所以我们从医院回家，大概是周日晚上甚至周一早上，我周一就来上班了。你来上班了。哦，天哪。我记得我很担心。我记得我当时就在想，只是在担心——我希望你们都还好。
Yeah. Just emotionally what that meant. Yeah. Everything worked out great. She's great. Walter's great. All aces. It's all aces.
是的。从情感上讲这意味着什么。是的。一切都结果很好。她很好。沃尔特很好。一切都好。一切都好。
And the first time I met your wife was when we were filming The Pilot. And I remember how you introduced me to her. I'll never forget it. You said- No. This is my wife, Carrier of my Seed. That's such a Dwight thing to say. Yeah.
我第一次见到你妻子是在我们拍试播集的时候。我记得你是怎么把我介绍给她的。我永远不会忘记。你说——不。这是我的妻子，我播种的载体。说得真像德怀特。是的。
We were like, oh, thanks for it. She was like, oh, hi, I'm Holly. Aw, great. The line blurs. Yeah. It definitely blurs between me and Dwight. I think the line blurs between all of us and our characters in some regard. For sure.
我们当时想，哦，谢谢。她当时说，哦，嗨，我是霍莉。哦，太棒了。界限模糊了。是的。我和德怀特之间的界限确实模糊了。我认为我们所有人与我们的角色在某种程度上界限都模糊了。肯定的。
Rain, thank you so much for talking with us on our podcast. Hey, this was great. I love the healthcare episode. And I'll have to- if you'll invite me back, I'll come into the studio and we can sit down and- Oh. Just have high fives and iced tea. Yes.
雷恩，非常感谢你在我们的播客上跟我们聊天。嘿，这太棒了。我很喜欢“医疗保健”那一集。我得——如果你邀请我回来，我会去录音室，我们可以坐下来——哦。击个掌，喝杯冰茶。是的。
Let's do that. Let's do that. And you guys, we have to all check out Rain's new podcast, Metaphysical Milkshake. Yep. And Rain, that is on what- where do we find that? It's on Luminary. Luminary. I'm gonna upload the Luminary app and it'll be right on that Luminary app.
我们就这么办。就这么办。各位，我们都得去看看雷恩的新播客《形而上学奶昔》（Metaphysical Milkshake）。是的。雷恩，那个在什么——我们在哪里可以找到它？它在Luminary上。Luminary。我要下载Luminary应用程序，它就在那个Luminary应用程序上。
Well, I can't wait to listen, Rain. I love you so much. Thank you. We love you. I love you guys and miss you. I'm so happy you're doing this podcast and the fans are just gonna love it. I hope so. All right.
嗯，我等不及要听了，雷恩。我太爱你啦。谢谢。我们爱你。我也爱你们，想念你们。很高兴你们在做这个播客，粉丝们一定会喜欢的。希望如此。好了。
All right, Rain. Okay, come back. Okay, we love you. Bye. Okay. See you soon. Bye. Thanks, guys.
好了，雷恩。好的，回来。好的，我们爱你。再见。好的。回头见。再见。谢谢你们，伙计们。
Why is it every time we talk to someone from the show, I want to start to cry? Like, I'm like tearing up a little. I don't know. I don't know that those relationships are so fundamental to us. Yes. They are like family and it doesn't- it's a crew member. It's a cast member. It doesn't matter.
为什么每次我们和剧里的人说话，我都想哭？就像，我有点泪目了。我不知道。我不知道这些关系对我们来说是多么根本。是的。他们就像家人一样，而且不管他是剧组人员，还是演员。这都没关系。
It's just such a special chapter in our lives and just hearing Rain's voice and him laughing at you and I being chatty. It just brought me straight back. Rain, thank you so much for coming on. That just made my day. Angela, I want to talk about something that was one of our other moments. One of the most popular questions and it came from a fan and it's something I was wondering about as well.
这只是我们生命中非常特殊的一个章节，只要听到雷恩的声音，听到他嘲笑你和我这么爱聊天。这就把我直接拉回去了。雷恩，非常感谢你来做客。这让我今天心情大好。安吉拉，我想聊聊另一刻的事情。最受欢迎的问题之一，它来自一个粉丝，这也是我一直在想的事情。
When I watched this episode, it has to do with the accounting department. Okay. So this is for you. Okay. Paige O. Murphy asked, I love how you get to see the start of the dynamic between the accounting department and healthcare. And this is when you're leaving the conference room and you say, you let him walk all over you.
当我看到这一集时，这跟会计部门有关。好吧。所以这是给你的。好吧。佩奇·O·墨菲问，我喜欢你如何能看到会计部门和“医疗保健”之间的动态关系的开始。这是当你离开会议室时，你说，你让他骑在你头上拉屎。
And I'm like, did you talk to him? Did you talk to him? What's that? I'm like, it's a pathetic. You let him walk all over you. And Kevin's like, what are you guys talking about? And I'm like, nothing, Kevin. Okay.
而我说，你跟他谈过了吗？你跟他谈过了吗？怎么回事？我说，这太可悲了。你让他骑在你头上拉屎。然后凯文说，你们在聊什么呢？我说，没什么，凯文。好吧。
So her question is how much of that was you guys improvising and how much was written? Uh-huh. This is to me like the quintessential accounting department dynamic. Yes. This is on my note card because to me, this really defined our corner this moment. Yeah. So let's watch it. And then I want to hear.
所以她的问题是，其中有多少是你们即兴发挥的，又有多少是写好的？嗯哼。对我来说，这就像是会计部门最典型的动态关系。是的。这在我的记事贴上，因为对我来说，这真正定义了我们这个角落的这一刻。是的。所以我们来看一下。然后我想听听。
I want to hear the real story. Okay. This is not good. This is ridiculous. Did you talk to him? What was that? You let him walk all over you. It's just pathetic.
我想听听真实的故事。好吧。这太糟糕了。这太荒谬了。你跟他谈过了吗？那是什么？你让他骑在你头上拉屎。这简直太可悲了。
What are you guys talking about? Nothing, Kevin. There it is. There it is. Okay. So, so, so we improvised that and here's the thing that I learned really quickly on this show and I learned it from our B camera operator, Matt Zone. Okay.
你们在聊什么呢？没什么，凯文。就是这样。就是这样。好吧。所以，所以，所以那是我们即兴发挥的，以下是我在这部剧里学到的一件很快的事，我是从我们的B机摄影师马特·佐恩那里学到的。好吧。
Matt was like, and if you guys have bits, make them quick and they have a chance of getting in the show. And so we had this moment where we were all walking back to our desk and Oscar and I kind of improvised this moment where I'm like, you know, did you talk to him and he's like, what was that? And then we kind of just had this chit chat on the way and our B camera operator got it and he was like, guys, if you tighten that up, it's going to make it, it'll make it in I think if you tighten it up.
马特当时说，如果你们有什么桥段，动作要快，它们就有机会进入正片。所以我们当时有这样一个时刻，我们都在走回办公桌，奥斯卡和我即兴发挥了这样一个时刻，我说，你知道，你跟他谈过了吗，他说，那是什么？然后我们在路上就这么闲聊起来，我们的B机摄影师拍到了，他说，伙计们，如果你们把这段收紧一点，它就能被采用，如果你们收紧一点，它就能进正片。
So we did. We had this back and forth and then of course, like I had no idea that Brian was already walking up behind us and so he was like, what are you talking about? I was just like, nothing, Kevin, and it just sort of crystallized that, you know, like Oscar and I have this like weird sort of like office, like dysfunctional marriage in a way, you know, and that Kevin is like our child that we're like, just stay out of it, leave him out of it. And it was just so fun that it made it in for us.
于是我们照做了。我们来回说了这些台词，然后当然，我根本不知道布莱恩已经跟在我们后面走过来了，所以他说，你们在聊什么呢，我就说，没什么，凯文，这就很自然地显现出，你知道的，我和奥斯卡之间有这种奇怪的，像办公室里那种功能失调的婚姻一样的关系，你知道的，而凯文就像是我们的孩子，我们就像是，别管这事，别把他牵扯进来。它能被放进正片，对我们来说真的太有趣了。
That was really fun. How did that dynamic come together? Because I know you guys would have to get stuck in the background. We've established that. But for real, you did. And I know you guys are all comedic and broad performers. Well, Oscar and I had done a show together, you know, we met well before the office. I've talked about this before.
那真的很有趣。这种动态关系是怎么形成的？因为我知道你们以前不得不被困在背景里。我们已经确定了这一点。但说实话，你们确实是。而且我知道你们都是喜剧和性格演员。嗯，奥斯卡和我曾一起合作过一个节目，你知道的，我们在《办公室》开拍很久之前就认识了。我以前谈过这个。
We had done a sketch show together called Hot Towel and we've known each other a long time. We had done the groundlings together and I think we just naturally fell into step with one another. I knew my character was always annoyed. That's like, that was like a base, my baseline is I was always annoyed. And then just the way that Brian did Kevin, he seemed a little bit like the idiot. So pretty much if I had anyone I could go to about something, it was Oscar and I was
我们曾一起做过一个名为《热毛巾》（Hot Towel）的小品秀，我们认识很久了。我们曾一起在“地上剧团”（The Groundlings）工作，我想我们很自然地就步调一致了。我知道我的角色总是很恼火。这就好像，这是作为一个基准，我的基准就是我总是很恼火。然后就是布莱恩扮演凯文的方式，他看起来有点像个傻子。所以基本上如果我有什么事可以找人倾诉，那就是找奥斯卡，我总是
always annoyed and I was always going to him and he never had the answers I wanted. And then I just didn't want to even talk to Kevin. So that just sort of like came about naturally, I think, and Oscar and I just picked up on all those cues. Well, I love that Greg and the directors gave our camera operators the license to pick up moments that they hadn't even been directed to pick up. Yeah, like they would keep one eye open on everything that was happening in the background and especially Matt, his job was to catch reactions and to catch these little moments
很恼火，我总是去找他，而他从来没有给我想要的答案。然后我甚至不想和凯文说话。所以这基本上就像是自然而然地发生了，我想，奥斯卡和我只是捕捉到了所有这些线索。嗯，我很喜欢格里格和导演们赋予我们的摄影师权力，让他们去捕捉他们甚至没有接到导演指令去捕捉的瞬间。是的，就像他们会用一只眼睛盯着背景中发生的一切，尤其是马特，他的工作就是捕捉反应，捕捉这些小瞬间
that were happening off of the main action. And Matt went on to direct episodes in later seasons. Yes, he did. And our director this episode, Ken Whittingham, was so great about letting us have that creative opportunity. So when he saw us do that as we walked away, he was like, yeah, yeah, keep doing that. And so he encouraged us. And then, you know, we used to joke that we would have just kept going and going.
发生在主线剧情之外的瞬间。后来马特在随后的几季中执导了多集。是的，他确实做到了。我们这集的导演肯·惠廷厄姆，在让我们拥有这种创意机会方面非常棒。所以当他看到我们边走边这样做时，他就说，对，对，继续这样做。所以他鼓励了我们。然后，你知道的，我们曾经开玩笑说我们会一直演下去，没完没了。
And so I'd be like, I'd have to say all, I would say all the time to Brian and Oscar, it's not, it's not our show, guys. It's not our show. It's not our show. And we had this whole like running bit that we did for years that there was an actual spin-off called Los Acanthodores, Oscar, Angela, y Kabeen. And it lived on Telemundo. That was our spin-off.
所以我会对布莱恩和奥斯卡说，我得一直对他们说，这不是我们的剧，伙计们。这不是我们的剧。这不是我们的剧。我们有一个持续了好几年的完整搞笑桥段，说其实有一个衍生剧叫《奥斯卡、安吉拉和卡宾》（Los Acanthodores, Oscar, Angela, y Kabeen）。它在Telemundo电视台播出。那是我们的衍生剧。
Angela, that is actually a really good idea for a spin-off. Just the accountants. The accountants. And Creed. And Creed. The accountants and Creed. The accountants. Well, I just think Creed has to work in every office.
安吉拉，这其实是一个很好的衍生剧创意。就只有会计们。会计们。还有克里德。还有克里德。会计们和克里德。会计们。好吧，我只是觉得克里德必须在每个办公室都工作。
Yes, somehow, right? Yes. Like he's always there. I actually would like Creed to be in every project. I need a phone number. Who's? I need to call someone at NBC. Who are you calling?
是的，不知怎么的，对吧？是的。就像他一直在那儿一样。我其实希望克里德能出现在每个项目中。我需要一个电话号码。谁的？我需要给NBC的某个人打电话。你在给谁打电话？
I don't know. I think this is gold. I actually would like Creed to just show up in every project I have for the rest of my life. Also, he texted me this morning and he really wants to come on the show. So I said... Well, he's coming on the show. Yeah, that's happening.
我不知道。我觉得这太棒了。我其实希望克里德能出现在我余下职业生涯中的每一个项目中。还有，他今天早上给我发短信了，他真的很想上这个节目。所以我说……好吧，他要上节目了。是的，这事儿会发生的。
I know exactly what episode too. Oh, you've got it. All figured out. Yeah, he needs to come on for the Halloween episode, which is the first episode that he speaks. No, Jenna, that is not the first episode that he speaks in. What? Yeah.
我也知道具体是哪一集。哦，你已经知道了。全都想好了。是的，他需要来参加万圣节那一集，那是他开口说话的第一集。不，珍娜，那不是他开口说话的第一集。什么？是的。
Look at it. Look at my note card. He has a few lines in this episode of healthcare. What? Creed does not speak in healthcare. Yes, he does. No, he does not. Lady, you have to listen.
看一看。看我的记事贴。他在“医疗保健”这一集里有几句台词。什么？克里德在“医疗保健”里根本没说话。是的，他说了。不，他没有。这位女士，你得听着。
Okay. So you know the scene when Michael calls the Lackawanna coal mine? Yes. For, you know, he's calling because he's like, hey, is there some kind of ride there? And there's a voice that's like, well, you know, it's an industrial elevator. It goes 300 feet into the ground really slowly. Yes. And Michael's like, what is there?
好吧。所以你知道迈克尔打电话给拉卡瓦纳煤矿的那场戏吗？是的。因为，你知道的，他打电话是因为他说，嘿，那儿有什么电梯吗？然后有个声音说，嗯，你知道的，这是一个工业电梯。它以非常慢的速度下降到地下300英尺。是的。迈克尔就说，那儿有什么？
Laser tag down there. And he's like, nope. Remember that guy? Yeah. It's Creed. What? Yes. The voice of the coal miner guy is Creed?
下面有激光枪战吗？然后他说，没有。还记得那个家伙吗？是的。那是克里德。什么？是的。那个煤矿工人的声音是克里德？
Yeah. No way. Well, this is... Between the two of us, I'm sure someone out there caught this, but I was watching this episode with my daughter and she was like, mommy, that voice sounds familiar. And I was like, it does. The voice of the man that works at the coal mine sounded familiar to us. And I was like, oh my gosh, it's Creed.
是的。开玩笑吧。好吧，这是——在我们两人之间，我确信外面有人注意到了这一点，但我当时正和女儿一起看这一集，她说，妈妈，那个声音听起来好熟悉。我就说，确实很熟悉。在煤矿工作的那个男人的声音对我们来说听起来很熟悉。然后我说，哦天哪，那是克里德。
It's Creed. And I texted Creed and he said, yeah, I was so excited. He said that Ken Kuapas, who was a friend of his, who was our director. He said, you know, Creed, why don't you read this? And Creed did. And they were really happy with it. And he really felt like that helped him sort of down the line for Halloween because they already thought he was funny.
是克里德。我给克里德发了短信，他说，是的，我太兴奋了。他说他的朋友肯·夸帕斯（Ken Kwapis），也是我们的导演。他说，你知道吗，克里德，你为什么不读读这个？然后克里德照做了。他们对这个非常满意。而且他真的觉得这在某种程度上对他以后拍万圣节那集很有帮助，因为他们已经觉得他很有趣了。
And he is so funny. He's so funny. And his timing is perfect. Perfect. Yes. But I want you to know, I said, Creed. Oh my gosh. So that was your first speaking part on the office was as that coal miner guy.
他确实太有趣了。他太有趣了。而且他的节奏完美无瑕。完美。是的。但我想让你知道，我说，克里德。哦天哪。所以你在《办公室》里的第一个有台词的角色就是那个煤矿工人。
Yeah. And he goes, no. What? I know. I know. This is episode three. I know. I know.
是的。然后他说，不。什么？我知道。我知道。这是第三集。我知道。我知道。
You don't know this. And I'm bouncing in my chair because you don't know this. Okay. The actual first time that Creed ever spoke was in diversity day. What? Yes. So at the time they needed some banter and our first AD did not realize that Creed wasn't in a series regular and didn't have a contract that he was just a background player.
你不知道这个。我在椅子上高兴得直蹦，因为你不知道这个。好吧。克里德真正第一次开口说话其实是在“多元化日”（Diversity Day）。什么？是的。所以当时他们需要一些闲聊，我们的第一副导演没有意识到克里德不是剧集的常规演员，也没有合同，他只是一个背景演员。
Just a background. They're literally like that. The contract for background player is you are not allowed to speak. If you speak, there's a big bump in pay. And they have to pay you. Yeah. Creed said, the AD said to him, can you fill in some banter with Phyllis? And Creed was like, you know me, Ange.
只是个背景演员。他们的规定字面意思是：背景演员是不准说话的。如果你说话，片酬会大幅上涨。他们必须付给你钱。是的。克里德说，副导演对他说，你能和菲莉丝随便聊上几句吗？克里德就说，安吉，你知道我的。
I'm not shy. So he has this banter with Phyllis and it made it in the episode. And then they realized they wanted to use it, but Creed wasn't officially under contract. So then they paid him and that is actually his first line. Well, my mind is blown. Your mind is blown because Creed actually had an improv line in diversity day that made it in the show. And that is the first time he spoke.
我不害羞。所以他和菲莉丝有了这段闲聊，而且它被剪进了正片。然后他们意识到他们想用这段，但克里德并没有正式签约。所以他们付了钱给他，那实际上是他的第一句台词。好吧，我惊呆了。你惊呆了，因为克里德在“多元化日”里确实有一句即兴台词被放进了正片。那是他第一次开口说话。
The second time he spoke was the elevator shaft operator guy on the phone with Michael. And then Halloween as we will get to is his big, big moment. Yes. Oh, that is some good stuff. That was a good note card, lady. Very good note card. Okay. Michael, well, I have trivia.
他第二次说话是在电话里和迈克尔通话的那个电梯井操作员。然后正如我们将要看到的，万圣节是他的超级大高潮。是的。哦，那真是好料。那是一张很好的记事贴，女士。非常好的记事贴。好吧。迈克尔，好吧，我有冷知识。
I have trivia. Why are you looking at me like that? I don't know. I have trivia. I've been feeling very smug with my. You are. My Creed trivia. Well, it was really good.
我有冷知识。你为什么那样看着我？我不知道。我有冷知识。我对我的……感到非常自密自信。你确实很自信。我的克里德冷知识。好吧，真的很不错。
All right. Here's mine. You know the scene when Michael goes to the travel agent, where he wants to try to get us the all expense paid trip to Atlantic City, where he says the thing about like, isn't there like bus that takes you there and then you get all your meals comped? Everything's free. Everything's free. And the travel agent is like, yeah.
好了。这是我的。你知道迈克尔去旅行社的那场戏吗，他想让我们去大西洋城享受一次全包旅行，他在那里说的那段话，是不是有那种带你去的巴士，然后你所有的餐费都可以报销？一切都是免费的。一切都是免费的。旅行社的人就说，是的。
I don't really know anything about that. You might want to just contact the casino directly. Do you know who played the travel agent? Is it his friend from college, Charlie Hartsock? Damn it. Angela. I remember that. I remember Steve was really excited because his friend from, you know, like his good friend
我其实对这个一无所知。你可能想直接联系赌场。你知道是谁扮演旅行社人员的吗？是他在大学时的朋友查理·哈特索克（Charlie Hartsock）吗？见鬼。安吉拉。我记得。我记得史蒂夫当时非常兴奋，因为他来自，你知道的，他很好的朋友
was going to be on set that day, but you weren't there that day. I wasn't Jenna, but Steve is my friend and he shared with me. Man. Uh-huh. All right. Well, what else have you got? We've got more note cards over there. You know what, Jenna, when I was watching this, I was like, oh my gosh, this really,
那天要来片场，但你那天不在。我不在，珍娜，但史蒂夫是我的朋友，他跟我分享了。天哪。嗯哼。好吧。那你还有什么？我们那边还有更多记事贴。你知道吗，珍娜，当我看到这里时，我想，哦天哪，真的，
this episode in particular, I felt like we really saw that, that peep shot. And I know we're going to talk about it. The spy shot. Angela, I call it the peep shot. Well, hey, please don't call it that to anyone else. It's called the spy shot. Well, you, you just called the spying. We're not peeping.
特别是这一集，我觉得我们真的看到了那种偷窥镜头。我知道我们要讨论它。秘密偷拍镜头。安吉拉，我叫它偷窥镜头。好吧，嘿，请不要在其他人面前这么叫它。这叫秘密偷拍镜头。好吧，你，你刚才叫偷窥。我们不是在偷窥。
Excuse me. You called the background actors lurkers. So we're lurking and we're peeping. Okay. But it's just that shot where you go through the blinds, right? Yeah. And we saw that a lot in this episode because Michael is hiding. He is hiding in his office and one of my favorite ones, when you're being sassy, the
不好意思。你把背景演员叫作潜伏者。所以我们在潜伏，也在偷窥。好吧。但就是那个镜头，你透过百叶窗看，对吧？是的。我们在这一集里经常看到这个，因为迈克尔在躲藏。他躲在办公室里，我最喜欢的其中一个镜头，就是你很傲慢的时候，
PAM. Oh my gosh. The PAM sass. The peep and a sass. It's a peep and a PAM sass. So we're looking through the blinds and Michael is just playing with his truck. He's rolling the truck. Yeah.
帕姆。哦，天哪。帕姆式的傲慢。偷窥加傲慢。这是偷窥加帕姆式的傲慢。所以我们透过百叶窗往里看，迈克尔正独自玩着他的卡车。他在推卡车。是的。
Back and forth. And he's claiming that there's many calls coming in. Yeah. Busy, busy, busy, busy. Still no one calling, still no one calling. It's matter of fact. You find matter of factness to be sass. No.
推来推去。他还宣称有很多电话打进来。是的。忙，忙，忙，忙。还是没人打电话，还是没人打电话。这是理所当然的。你觉得这种理所当然就是傲慢。不。
I think there's a little bit of sass on it. But yeah. So I thought, I love that you got to see how we spy on people through the camera, that we get to see these moments. They don't know that we're seeing. Yeah. And you'll see it over and over. But when I watched the BBC version of this show and then when I watched our version, those
我觉得里面带有一点傲慢。但是，是的。所以我想，我喜欢你能看到我们是如何通过摄像机监视人们的，我们能看到这些时刻。他们不知道我们在看。是的。你会一次又一次地看到它。但是当我观看这部剧的BBC版本，然后观看我们的版本时，那些
were the only shows doing that at this time. We were really trying to employ what you would do on an actual documentary where you want to like catch people when they're not aware they're being filmed. And we behave differently when we are being, know we're being filmed or not. And so that was, we would use the spy shot when we needed to catch people. Or the peep shot. Okay. Or the peep shot as Angela is calling it.
是当时唯一在这样做的剧集。我们真的在试图运用你在实际纪录片中会做的事情，即你想在人们不知道自己被拍摄时捕捉他们。当我们知道自己被拍摄或不知道自己被拍摄时，我们的行为是不同的。所以那是，当我们需要捕捉人们时，我们会使用秘密偷拍镜头。或者偷窥镜头。好吧。或者像安吉拉所说的偷窥镜头。
Moving on. Moving on. All right. Next card. Two observations about John in this episode. The first one has to do with his hair. John has a full-on bowl haircut in this. What?
继续。继续。好吧。下一张卡片。关于这一集里的约翰的两个观察。第一个与他的发型有关。约翰在这个造型里顶着一个彻头彻尾的锅盖头。什么？
Yes. Sam, can you pull up a picture of John in this to show Jenna? I grew up in a small town and some of these farm boys, they would just put a bowl on their head and cut their hair around it. What was that about? I don't know. Look at that. Oh, it's a bowl.
是的。山姆，你能调出一张约翰在这一集里的照片给珍娜看看吗？我在一个小镇长大，有些农家男孩，他们会把一个碗扣在头上，然后沿着碗边剪头发。那是怎么回事？我不知道。看那个。哦，是个锅盖头。
Oh, it's 14 minutes and 19 seconds. That's full bowl. Full bowl. Okay. And then the other thing I noticed about John is that John says D-white. He does say D-white. He says D-white. D-white.
哦，在14分19秒。那是绝对的锅盖头。绝对的锅盖头。好吧。然后我关于约翰注意到的另一件事是，约翰说的是“D-white”（德怀特）。他确实说的是“D-white”。他说的是“D-white”。D-white。
I say D-white. I say D-white. He said, well, he doesn't say D-white. He says D-white. D-white. Okay. D-white. John says D-white.
我说的是“D-white”。我说的是“D-white”。他说，好吧，他不说“D-white”。他说的是“D-white”。D-white。好吧。D-white。约翰说的是“D-white”。
D-white. D-white. D-white. Oh, my God. John says D-white. And I say D-white. I say D-white. D-white.
D-white。D-white。D-white。哦，天哪。约翰说的是“D-white”。我说的是“D-white”。我说的是“D-white”。D-white。
I absolutely love it now because it just makes me miss John. And every time I hear him say D-white, it just makes me smile. So there are my two John observations. And I have an observation about Jim in this episode, which is, and actually, if Fan pointed this out as well, I had noticed it, but I will give some props to the other person who noticed it, except I don't have their name written down. I'm sorry. Person out there, you know who you are.
我现在简直爱死它了，因为它让我想念约翰。每次听到他说“D-white”，我就忍不住微笑。所以这就是我对约翰的两个观察。我有一个关于这一集里的吉姆的观察，那就是，实际上，如果有粉丝也指出了这一点，我之前就注意到了，但我还是要向另一个注意到这一点的人致敬，不过我没有记下他们的名字。对不起。外面的那个人，你知道你是谁。
Which is that all of this could have been avoided if Jim had just taken 15 minutes and picked a plan. No, I know. No, he- The way he was asked in the beginning of the episode. Yes. And he ends up having this fun, playful day with Pam, but if we're going to get real here, it cost him and everyone else in the office decent health care.
那就是这一切本可以避免，如果吉姆当时肯花15分钟定个计划的话。不，我懂。不，他——他在剧集开头被要求做这件事时的态度。是的。最后他和帕姆度过了愉快、顽皮的一天，但如果我们现在要面对现实的话，这让他和办公室里的其他所有人都失去了体面的医疗保健。
On the other hand, in his defense, I will say the task was to slash the health care. So I'm not sure he could have done much better than D-white, but maybe he could have. Well- Does it make him kind of not as charming? I don't know. Well, I think what happens- This is an argument. I think what happens in this show is that Michael passes the buck to Jim and Jim passes
另一方面，为他辩护一下，我会说任务是削减医疗保健。所以我不确定他能比“D-white”做得更好，但也许他能。好吧——这难道不让他显得没那么有魅力了吗？我不知道。好吧，我想发生的是——这是一个争论。我认为这部剧中发生的事情是，迈克尔把责任推给吉姆，吉姆又把责任推给德怀特，这种情况一次又一次地发生。
it to Dwight and it happens over and over. It does. It does. And Jim is just like, listen, I don't get paid enough to do this. Yeah. Well, and I think the argument really can be made that Jim knew it was inevitable. Like what we ended up with is what we were going to end up with, although the other argument can be made that Dwight made it worse than it needed to be.
确实如此。确实如此。吉姆当时的想法就像是，听着，我拿的薪水可不干这个。好吧，而且我认为确实可以这样辩论：吉姆知道这是不可避免的。就像我们最终得到的结果就是我们注定要得到的结局，尽管也可以提出另一个论点，即德怀特把事情弄得比原本需要的更糟糕。
Okay. I have another note card. Okay. Okay. Here it is. One of the things I love about our props department is just all the little details in the back. And a great example of this is all of the motivational posters that you see around Dunder Mifflin.
好吧。我还有一张记事贴。好吧。好吧。给你。我喜欢我们的道具部门的一点，就是背景中的所有小细节。这方面的一个绝佳例子就是你在整个邓德米夫林公司周围看到的各种励志海报。
There's so many. They're brilliant. They're brilliant. I like to think that like Michael Scott really thinks they're going to get everyone to like feel affirmed in their day. So you know, there's one behind you in reception that just says teamwork. Yep. And it's a bunch of people.
有那么多。它们太棒了。它们太棒了。我倾向于认为迈克尔·斯科特真的认为它们能让每个人在一天中都感到被肯定。所以你知道，你接待处后面就挂着一张，上面写着“团队合作”。是的。上面是一群人。
They've jumped out of a plane and they're all locking arms. That teamwork. But these are all over the office though. At 15 minutes, 50 seconds around there, it flashes to the clock on the wall. And under the clock, you just see it says self affirmations, self esteem. And then you can't see what else it says, but I'm like, what is under the clock? What are all these self affirmations? The detail work in our set design was incredible.
他们从飞机上跳下来，手挽着手。这就是团队合作。但这些海报在整个办公室到处都是。在15分50秒左右，镜头闪到了墙上的时钟。在时钟下面，你看到上面写着“自我肯定”、“自尊”。然后你看不到它还写了什么，但我当时就在想，时钟下面是什么？所有这些自我肯定都是什么？我们布景设计中的细节工作简直不可思议。
And that was Michael Gallenberg. He was our set designer. He was so amazing. So many details and then the props department would any time there was some sheet of paper that we had to look at as a prop, it was a fully formed idea. You know, if there was a memo, they wrote out like a whole real fake memo and they were funny. Under the plane stationary.
那是迈克尔·盖伦伯格（Michael Gallenberg）。他是我们的布景设计师。他太棒了。有那么多的细节，然后道具部门每当有我们需要当作道具看的纸张时，那都是一个完全成型的想法。你知道，如果有一份备忘录，他们就会写出一整份真实假冒的备忘录，而且它们都很有趣。飞机文具下面。
There's always funny little jokes hidden in them. And also all around the office, if you're in the break room, the menus, the magnets on the fridge, they're all from Scranton. They reached out to local businesses in Scranton and they all sent their items and they're all throughout our office. Also, of course, Froggy, 95.5 local Scranton radio. That's what should be your playlist. You should have just listened to some Froggy.
里面总是藏着各种好笑的小笑话。此外，在整个办公室里，如果你在休息室，菜单、冰箱上的磁贴，全都是来自斯克兰顿的。他们联系了斯克兰顿当地的企业，企业把他们的物品都寄了过来，这些物品遍布我们的办公室。当然还有，“青蛙95.5”（Froggy 95.5）当地斯克兰顿广播电台。这应该是你的播放列表。你本来应该听听“青蛙”电台的。
I really should have. All right. This episode ends with Michael coming out of his office. He's successfully hidden in his office until 5pm after 5pm. And the entire office is waiting to confront him, both about the horrible healthcare plan that Dwight picked, and to finally find out, please, what is the surprise? Yes. Because he's come in attempting to surprise us with ice cream sandwich.
我真的应该听的。好了。这一集的结尾是迈克尔从他的办公室出来。他在办公室里成功躲到了下午5点之后。整个办公室都在等着找他算账，不仅是为了德怀特选的那个糟糕的医疗保健计划，还要最终弄清楚，求求你了，惊喜到底是什么？是的。因为他走进来时企图给我们一个冰淇淋三明治作为惊喜。
Oh, he about hit me in the head with an ice cream sandwich. I mean, Steve actually, like, look at the look on his face after that take. I was like, he was like, how close did that come? I was like, Steve, you pretty much almost hit me in the head with it. And he also announced so proudly, operation surprise. Yes. And so we're like, okay, what is it? What is it?
哦，他差点用冰淇淋三明治砸到我头上。我是说，史蒂夫实际上，就像看他拍完那一条之后的表情。我当时想，他当时在想，刚才离得有多近？我当时想，史蒂夫，你差点就用它砸到我头上了。而且他还那么骄傲地宣布“惊喜行动”。是的。所以我们当时就想，好吧，到底是什么？到底是什么？
And it's all he could come up with in his whole day was ice cream sandwiches. So now it's the end. And then he says that's not the surprise. It's surprising, but it is not the surprise. So at the end of the episode, you confront him. I do. I love it. I loved being the person that confronted him because Steve is so funny and he turned
结果他折腾了一整天，想出来的竟然只是冰淇淋三明治。所以现在到了结尾。然后他说那不是惊喜。这很令人惊讶，但它不是那个惊喜。所以在这一集快结束时，你去找他算账了。我去了。我太喜欢了。我喜欢成为找他算账的那个人，因为史蒂夫太搞笑了，他把他
him in. He's like, yes, Angela, thank you for reminding me. So you ask him point blank, what is the surprise, Michael? And then he says the surprise is. And then he short circuits, he just stops talking, he just stops talking and it just starts to have like upper lip sweat. And we all are just looking at him. It is so awkward.
弄得哑口无言。他说，是的，安吉拉，谢谢你提醒我。所以你开门见山地问他，惊喜是什么，迈克尔？然后他说，惊喜是。接着他短路了，他不说话了，他就是不说话了，上嘴唇开始冒汗。我们所有人都只是看着他。这太尴尬了。
It's so awkward. And I remember when we did it, like timing it out to that moment where we start to like slowly leave each person. And how long that felt. Yes. It felt so long. It really did as we were standing there. And they had choreographed the order in which we would leave.
这太尴尬了。我记得我们拍这一段的时候，计算好时间，到了那个我们每个人开始慢慢离开的时刻。那感觉有多漫长。是的。我们站在那儿的时候，感觉真的好漫长。确实如此。他们还排练了我们离开的先后顺序。
And of course we did many takes, so we would have to come back and reset. And I remember thinking, are we going to leave this? This is a giant pause with no dialogue. Is this going to be able to stand because that was not something you did on television shows. In fact, on television shows, especially comedies, it was pretty traditional to have like set up, set up, joke, set up, set up, joke. And this was like a whole different rhythm.
当然我们拍了很多条，所以我们不得不回来重新摆好位置。我当时心想，我们要离开这里吗？这是一个没有台词的巨大停顿。这能行得通吗？因为这可不是你在电视节目里会做的事。事实上，在电视节目中，尤其是喜剧中，有铺垫、铺垫、笑话、铺垫、铺垫、笑话，这可以说是相当传统的节奏。而这就像是一种完全不同的节奏。
And so, yeah, I remember this. And I remember he just had to stand there. Oh, it was so awkward. And then when you watch it, it's so like cringey, but it's perfect. It's perfect. It's so good. And I, there's so many times, like when I watch episodes of The Office where I'm like, how does Michael come back from that?
所以，是的，我记得这一幕。我记得他就得那么站在那里。哦，太尴尬了。然后当你看着它的时候，感觉非常尴尬，但它是完美的。完美。太棒了。而且，我有好多次，比如当我看《办公室》的时候，我会想，迈克尔怎么能从那种局面中翻盘？
Like I say that to myself. Like how does he come back the next day and be like, we all knew there was no surprise. We all knew, but man, we made him suffer through that pause. And then best last line ever after that suffering silence, Rain says, oh, Jan wants you to call her. So good. So good. That's healthcare guys.
就像我对自己这么说。就像他第二天怎么能回来，然后若无其事地说，我们都知道根本没有什么惊喜。我们全都知道，但是天哪，我们让他经受了那种停顿的折磨。然后在那段饱受折磨的沉默之后，史上最棒的最后一句话来了，雷恩说，哦，简想让你给她回个电话。太棒了。太棒了。这就是医疗保健，伙计们。
That is healthcare. Thank you so much, Rainn Wilson for calling in and it was just so great to hear your voice. And guys, if we missed anything, remember you can write us at officeladiesatearwolf.com and just put the, put the episode name in the subject line so that we can easily sort through things. Put the episode in the subject line or Jenna's going to be ticked off. I won't be ticked off. You're going to get some PAM sass.
这就是医疗保健。非常感谢雷恩·威尔逊打电话进来，能听到你的声音真是太棒了。伙计们，如果我们漏掉了什么，记得可以给我们写信：officeladiesatearwolf.com，只要在主题行里写上剧集名称，这样我们就能轻松分类了。把剧集名称写在主题行里，否则珍娜可要生气的。我才不会生气呢。你会得到一些帕姆式的傲慢。
You're going to get some PAM sass. You might get PAM sass. Oh, I'm just going to go listen to the sounds of Scranton. I'll be right back. I'll see you guys next week. See you next week when we do the Alliance. The Alliance. Oh, there's so much good stuff in that one.
你会得到一些帕姆式的傲慢。你可能会得到帕姆式的傲慢。哦，我正要去听听斯克兰顿的声音。我马上回来。我们下周见。下周我们要聊“联盟”（The Alliance），回见。“联盟”。哦，那一集里有太多好东西了。
Not to be missed. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Peefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Remember you can listen to ad-free versions of Office Ladies on Stitcher Premium. For a free month of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
千万不要错过。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是山姆·佩弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。请记住，你可以在Stitcher Premium上收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本。输入优惠码 Office，即可免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。